honestly i couldn't believe some of the
behavior that came out of christine and
i was genuinely questioning i'm like is
someone capable of being this cold or is
it just sort of played up for the show
unfortunately it's you know it's real
might even be a little softened for the
show so yeah
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters of all time
sophia and sistine
sophia yes i have a question for you
what is that
are you lost baby girl
oh i'm not lost anymore because that
movie last night was
heinous okay so if you guys don't know
what we're talking about sistine hi last
night
watched
365 days the sequel to that let me
explain
if you are somewhat of a kinky person
you have seen this
movie of it they make
50 shades of gray look like child's play
and it's on netflix and the first one
was so graphic it blew up during
quarantine it was awesome yeah so they
moved it from like some random website
to netflix because it was so popularized
on tick tock and so
we watched it obviously on netflix and
it was awesome several times several
times just and then we
i just realized we showed a cousin it
too
i showed our cousin i showed her a
little sister i showed my best friend i
showed everyone under the sun and they
liked it because well we gave him a
preface and what was well first of all
it was peak quarantine no one has seen
or touched another human being in months
yeah it was the only form of intimacy it
was literally like amongst all the bad
happening in the world we got something
good that's true that's true diamond in
the rough glimmer of hope so
the second one came out of course the
same night the day it came out said
we're watching it tonight right yeah
obviously we sit on the couch we are
ready to go
is there such thing as too much sex yeah
can i tell you guys the first
30 minutes
is maybe four lines of dialogue yeah and
just pure raw animalistic sex that is
probably close to being porn no i'll be
honest 40 actually 45 minutes and we're
halfway through
still have no idea what the plot is yeah
there's no plot apparently it has an
identical twin we just ruined some
things
don't waste your time it was
like sophie and i were watching it and
before we'd be like oh my god that is so
sexy look at that well
yeah yeah
yeah
then every time they would do something
we were like oh gosh
well they would fight for two seconds
about something and then she'd come in
and lingerie suddenly from head to toe
after two minutes
no it was growing at her literally a sex
scene would go on for six minutes it was
cornball central like my favorite scene
it was horrible my favorite scene was
they're sitting at the christmas dinner
table
and everyone's exchanging gifts and the
kids are there and he's like where is my
present and then she's like
you'll get it later be patient you know
and we were all like oh i wonder what it
is sex sex like
like we've only seen it 12 times
like guys and we're we're big fans of
this movie we hate it we're hating this
we're big fans of sex
we hated it so sorry you guys like
whoever made that movie you guys messed
up i don't know what you did in the
crossfire but like i get that people
loved the sex in the first one but
there's there is too much sex so we've
learned today and also he didn't say his
iconic line are you lost baby girl no
and to be honest
what's his name massimo
i was lost
i was
so
moving on it
was lost
this baby girl was very lost
[Music]
we love to discuss fun topics on this
podcast as you guys know from everything
such as dating health and wellness and
everything in between but we are so
excited to bring something to the show
that will hopefully help you guys save
and budget well welcome to unfiltered
finance brought to you by
money lion
as if you haven't heard it before but
guys moneyline is a financial app full
of innovative products that are designed
to help you with your own money life
download it today in the app store it
combines motivation knowledge products
and offers personalized app experience
to help you own your money life every
single day
i don't know about you sophia but i
think we can agree
that my online shopping addiction could
use a bit of budgeting help and i think
you i actually think it used to be you
but now it's me so perhaps we could
budget for you i think we could both
agree upon that so there's so many
things we need to do budget like rent
utilities car insurance gas food and
don't get me started on all my monthly
subscriptions i love peacock reality
shows you got to get into it so we also
have to remind ourselves to put a
percentage into our savings so that
we're ready for emergencies and those
big purchases later in life or those big
purchases right around the corner you
know i like to live in the moment but i
still want to be prepared for it you
never know when the perfect pair of
shoes is going to pop up on your screen
those pesky ads there are so many
categories to balance and budget for
that there's no wonder we need the extra
tools moneyline provides to help make
the budgeting process easier i mean
we're kind of going overboard a little
bit with how much we're traveling here
so
maybe i'm a little worried for you how
can i forget or more like you won't let
me forget sofia
what can i say you know i love a
memorable vacation luckily moneyline
helped me to get back on track so i can
feel confident about what i'm spending
my hard earned money on and able to live
my best life with moneyline well for one
thing i'm actually so proud because
you've improved a lot since you're
budgeting problems and overspending well
you don't go you know but we love
confidence when it comes to money
spending everything that comes along
with it budgeting is a life skill that
can benefit anybody no matter where we
are in life so it's really important to
start learning about it in our 20s and
it definitely makes it easier to build
those skills at an earlier age and i've
already benefited so much for what i
learned and i know you guys can too as
well as christine i agree i mean i know
i've definitely learned a lot i know
that we both have very strong work
ethics and have been able to make our
own way in the world or at least we're
trying which is why it's important that
we know how to budget correctly to help
be in control of our own money life
we got to stop blowing all of our money
on stagecoach outfits okay i know
not the worst purchase but i definitely
know it's not the best that's why i've
made a section for it in my budget i'm
prepared now so my addiction doesn't
cause my budget to go into a little
downward spiral mom dad are you proud of
us because we're starting to budget so
guys you can do the same thing so get
control of your money life today and go
on the app store and download moneyline
and make sure your budgeting journey is
so much smoother
moneyline
[Music]
you know what else we've been watching
is that johnny depp trial i watch it
like it's a reality show on the
treadmill i it's probably i'm not i'm
not saying that this is not a big deal
it's a big deal but it's really
entertaining to watch i've never seen
something like this in my life
it is right up there with real
housewives of new jersey right now
it is
so good
did you see that everyone started a
gofundme and it's like
it's reached over 100 000 to legally
change amber heard's name to amber turd
it's so bad no but it's such a i feel
like obviously not realness it's really
this whole entire trial is kind of
insane it just shows that i don't know
just i think it's more crazy that we're
able to watch every single thing that
goes on in this courtroom with such a
high profile company you know what it is
too and i just realized this because
it's on you can watch it on tick tock
you can watch on instagram live facebook
people can comment now on trials because
usually it's you have a court and then
you have judges and you have the people
that are going to make the decision
whether they're guilty or not but now
anybody can literally be in the room and
make a comment on a court case and see
every single detail and pick up on
things i find that insane and sometimes
i'm watching it like the psychologist
that did a whole evaluation on amber the
other day and was saying that she has
borderline personality disorder and all
this stuff it's like parts i'm like oh
did you see her like smirking at that
well it's also crazy too because it is
such a
uh public trial that
the things that she's saying in the
courtroom
like for example that she
had a case of makeup with her all of the
time to cover up bruising on her face
they were able to fact check that
because the company in which she ordered
that specific makeup palette from pulled
up the receipt and showed that it was
actually two years after she broke up
with johnny that yeah i just i mean it's
crazy that even now people can fact
check her yeah it's like we're all in
the courtroom we're all deciding whether
or not this is a guilty person i'm not
guilty i mean i'm not taking any sides
we are switzerland here but it is just
so crazy to watch like i i wake up in
the morning i'm like okay is this when's
the depth
yeah but you know what's interesting
that the kardashians are in the same
sort of situation right now
with blac chyna yeah yeah i did hear i
don't know no one's paying attention to
that trial at all because this one is so
big yeah but can you live stream that
i don't know that's what i'm confused
about it's just like the only
i don't know but i i think after this i
need to stop i'm i live what did i say
the other day i've been watching and i
said media adjourned i was having a
meeting with our malka team and i said
okay guys media adjourned
casually like that's a normal thing to
say maybe we should just start saying it
but other than that cysteine has a big
problem and actually now it's caused me
to have a big problem because of how
many freaking videos she sends me every
single day she wants a cat
she wants a cat so bad and it's popping
up now all over my instagram page cats i
don't i mean i like cats i'm not the
biggest fan of cats but this [ __ ] sends
me calico cats in every position every
drinking water running around on their
backs on their stomach
are you done running your mouth
i want to buy this one it doesn't pull
the trigger that's the worst part she
said these
it's been what a week doesn't pull the
trigger
i'm sorry it's a 15-year commitment i
gotta make sure it's the right choice
sophia
second of all it's not a problem yes am
i lonely in my apartment absolutely do i
think a furry friend would help me
distract from myself yeah i would like
that so um i told mom and dad actually
the other day i was like look you guys
i don't want to hear it i don't want
your judgment i don't want your advice i
don't want anything except i just want
to let you know i'm buying a cat and
they were like absolutely not you can
barely take care of yourself you're not
getting a cotton as a first of all rude
second of all i can do it my dad said
get a hamster
gross gross well blood hamster didn't
work out i thought okay maybe i should
do a little trial run
so i'm on the google yesterday
and
i filled out an application to foster a
kitten
a kitten a kitten
i'm fostering a cat which i'm so excited
about they come back to me this morning
wait wait oh what you followed through
yeah so i just went out i [ __ ] on her
for like two minutes yeah an [ __ ] but
here's the best part i go on this
website because i said you could foster
cats kittens dogs other
what is other you ask please tell me
it's a ferret
you can foster hamsters
why would you foster a hammer that's my
point you can foster a small rat or like
a little mouse you can foster a turtle
you can i mean turtles are smelly i mean
how funny is that that is pretty funny
we should just show you guys a turtle
and just let it because she's getting
one of each put in your apartment then
you're distracted as a whole i know yeah
yeah so i'm gonna foster a kitten you
guys can join for the journey um
what do you want to name them puss
oh sistine
okay i got one yes one though yeah gabby
wanted to put some boots gabby wants to
have a dog rat how dumb is that
no rat she said it right
rats remember at disneyland she kept
saying she wants guys
jesus
i don't know what just happened there i
think it's demonic for a second but yeah
she wants to name it rat
i'm not naming my cat bra i was a cat
it's worse
it's like naming it tom and jerry
well you are so judgmental you said it
was a shitty name too
rat yes
it is pretty bad
okay so i'm so excited to move on from
cats rats and dogs and whatever
we're going to stagecoach ye freaking
haul baby
giddy up
giddy up you know what they say save a
horse ride a cowboy i'm so excited i am
so excited um i have to say my outfits i
put in very minimal effort old me would
have spent about two days planning this
and i am like you know what i don't care
i want to go for the good vibes the good
music
and that's about you pulled to sophia i
pulled to sustain this time i actually
put effort into my outfits i never do
and i always end up overthinking them
and then thinking i look ugly and then i
ruin my time there because i plan out
what i'm gonna wear to a tee then i
overthink it and if it doesn't look like
how i thought it was gonna look in my
head that's when i started that's why i
try it on two days before but
if i know
jean shorts and a white tank top looks
good on me
that'll do yeah that's like simple
sometimes nothing is better than doing
the belt with the choker and the
earrings and the thing and the boots and
the so what i'm doing wiki you know what
i've been listening to just to change up
the topic what why are you laughing
laughing at gabby gee i know i was
listening to this morning getting ready
and i think this was subconscious old
hannah montana music i was listening to
if we were a movie hoedown throwdown um
the what was the ending song in uh
hannah montana movie you can change your
hair and you can change change your
clothes you can change them that was the
way it
such a good song i loved it
oh no not really for me i never really
liked the hannah montana movie i
remember we used to learn pop it locket
pokemon
the fact i remember i don't even know
where he is now it's just it wasn't for
me
really i liked rico
who's rico
the little kid rico in it oh
i can't believe i forgot actually i met
him recently
do you remember the sun on the man
they've got the cheese
i'm the man who got the jerky you put it
all together and dude you're really
working cheese
turkey say what say what cheese drink
all right
so i feel like this whole entire uh
intro has been a lot about pop culture
but you know what
we love pop culture we like getting
involved in other people's lives
especially since they like to just
openly say it just like megan fox just
said on an interview that her and mgk
casually just drank each other's blood
well she described it as a ritual
and she was saying that you know it's
for ritual purposes they just prick a
little bit but she goes yeah
colson sometimes is literally like rip
my chest open and just suck the blood
out and i think that's kind of dangerous
well she was so at first she co it
totally is dangerous
ish i mean i don't know i don't want to
judge people that are drinking each
other's blood no like it's vampire
diaries but they can judge um no she
said at first it was a couple drops and
then she says that he likes to do the
whole let me cut my chest open and she
says apparently well we don't need to do
that but then she goes and says but he's
done it quite a few times
man i would love to be a fly on that
wall i don't think i would i mean i feel
like there's some dark magic going on
there i feel like
she i think she she can cast a spell or
something when that happens i think she
believes that she can though i don't i
actually i think
she has like a higher power
and she's in to the very you know
zodiac
read people's minds predict things in
the future she's very into all that i
wish i could be like that i feel like i
don't i don't have any sorcery or so you
if people walk up to cesine and say that
she has some sort of
power and that or some weird empathetic
the amount of presents and empanadas
because we just interviewed someone that
has that weirdo we have emma hernan on
today and should we talk to empanadas
she has some weird empanadas there's
been abilities three or four instances
where i've gotten tapped by a stranger
on the shoulder and they say i don't
want to freak you out
but i feel like i need to tell you this
i'm a psychic i'm a medium i'm a reader
and they all tell me all this stuff like
one time i was with my ex i know exactly
where we were
and she goes
this ain't it i was like what do you
mean she goes yeah literally this isn't
right something's not right here well
she was right
she was right she was pretty right but i
think i just had something clicking me
do you think your powers would be
full-fledged and come out if you drank
someone's blood
to activate them
maybe we should ask our guest if she can
suck
this poor girl
i think you need some of my blood
your blood nasty hey what the heck how
do you know my blood's nasty i can just
tell okay so sophie and i are obsessed
with the show selling sunset i binged it
i think in a total of three days when i
reached out to the guests that we have
on today i was so shocked and freaking
excited that she responded so quickly so
we have emma hernan coming on if you
don't know which one she is look for the
bubbly bright tall tall blonde who's
stunning and a badass businesswoman
that's her so we have her on today we're
going to talk about starting your own
business
you know
friendships in the workplace boys and
then her start on selling sunset and
everything in between it's a really good
episode you guys will love her as much
as we do so stay tuned
[Music]
you guys today we're so excited to have
on this beautiful woman because not only
will you recognize her from the wildly
popular netflix series selling sunset
she's also a business badass she is a
former sports illustrated model and of
course she's a real estate agent as you
know from the show this is ella hernan
oh my god wait i'm so excited to be here
okay you guys are the cutest things yeah
wait i have to say just sort of break
the ice i saw you at the last super bowl
and you were walking through i don't
even know what the area was it was like
wait the this last one yeah we were like
in the same box area and i remember
seeing you and you're walking by and you
were just so
bubbly and happy and you know how she
actually did say this to me after yeah
and i looked at you and i was like first
of all she's so stunning but you know
some people just have an aura about them
that is so positive like i got that vibe
from you and i was like she seems like a
really sweet person so i just have to
say like i saw you and i was like oh my
god oh i love that i definitely feel
like you know on the show you get to see
a lot of my personality but i'm way like
goofier in person yeah like i mean i'm
the person that like when you know when
we were in high school like mooning
people out the car like i'm just like
wild like you made people out the car
yeah like why not there's gonna be a
headline now oh gosh that was perfect
yeah no no but yeah i like i love to
have fun like i'm always like truth or
dare like i want dare and i'm like yeah
i think it's better like i feel like i
can see the goofiness a little bit from
the show but i feel like people resonate
that way more than just like if you're
perfect 24 7. like it's fun to see some
personality i mean that's what's like
everyone's been followers but i'm not i
think you're a real person the first
season that you jumped onto the show you
were very like straightener boss woman
you came in you conquered and you were
my favorite right off the bat because
not only did you have real estate under
your belt you had your own business you
were i mean we'll get into all of that
after but then this recent season you
were definitely more of a personality
you were more yourself more bubbly so we
saw different versions of you do you
hope that for possibly the next season
you want to share even more
of your personality that people haven't
seen
yeah i mean i like when people get to
know like the real me i mean i have
probably like the biggest heart out of
anyone like i'm the type of person like
i'm a giver like i actually prefer to
like give presents and like make other
people happy right so i would love for
people to see more of that and like see
more of my goofy side because it's fun
like you see all the little challenges i
don't know if you see them on like
social media of like you know me and
christelle doing like that's the stuff
that i do with my friends right i love
to have fun and so i would love for you
know right people to get to know me more
you know yeah i'm a business woman and
stuff like that but i also am like you
know just
honey
happy-go-lucky
yeah did you want to join like before
you joined the show was this something
that you were like initially going i
gotta get on it no not the opportunity
like why oh you were hesitant for sure
so why
i think it was one of those things where
i'm a super private person i've been
super private my whole life no one even
know what i did for a living right
everyone was like how does she have like
like a range rover like stupid things
like that i remember you know people
saying to me before like they just
assumed i was dating somebody with money
or i came from you know a wealthy family
right nobody knew and everyone judges
you know and
i just you know chose to kind of keep it
personal to me and everything so opening
up not only like my personal life and
everything like that but also to like
dating and things like that i've just
exposed i was engaged and i didn't you
know post it on social media because it
was just something that like i wanted
between you it was just i've always been
a private person so definitely some
hesitation right
once you so once you join a show like
that it's like opening pandora's box to
your life it's almost like it gives
every person watching the opportunity to
like nail on you love you whatever it is
oh yeah exactly love you hate you like
but your life is judged from that point
i mean we'll get into the pressure of
that but i read somewhere that you were
part of the oppenheim group even before
the show started yeah how did you know
the timing was right i've you know i've
been part of you know the group for a
while jason and brett were like my big
brothers and i was close with a lot of
the girls but you know i think that they
were looking to like bring on you know
some new cast numbers and things like
that so you know what the producers
reached out to me and it was it wasn't
like an easy no-brainer decision it was
something that i really had to weigh out
because i have my other businesses i
have other things going on where can i
put the time in anything i do i like to
do a hundred percent right and not only
that am i ready to open up my life i
like everybody to you know and you're
representing your brand you're like yeah
yeah i don't get portrayed well in the
show like is it gonna hurt the other
businesses that i worked really hard for
a hundred percent
better or worse than you thought it
would be just the whole
i guess we'll say the first time you're
the first season you're on was it just
harder than you thought was a more time
commitment than you thought or was it
definitely more of a time commitment
okay for sure definitely like didn't
realize the amount of time that was
going to go into it yeah i think that's
why i do want my family to you know move
them closer here because i went from
going back and forth all the time and
being with my family you know a month in
boston a month here right to now like
you know if they're i can't fly back as
much but definitely more of a time
commitment than i ever imagined i
remember this last season you
one of your missions was to find your
mom a house
and the one that you liked for her kind
of just wait the one that i actually put
an offer in on you know mary's client
got it yeah that's my point i mean
that's so weird with this show it's like
basically
was that real oh no that was like not
planned no no no that was real and the
agent wouldn't tell the agent was like
honestly this i've never had this happen
but i think you need to talk to somebody
at your brokerage so i didn't know it
was mary at first and so i'm like what
is going on she the the other agent
literally said i've never experienced
this before this has never happened
that's hard because you want to support
your friend mary
but you also want your mom to have this
house i honestly have to say that was
like the one that the house that got
away oh wait so you didn't find it no i
haven't found another one and now the
market's insane so it's not even a good
time to buy right now it's like the
worst time the worst time to buy great
time to sell so you know i'm kind of
like [ __ ] but i'm happy for mary right
and honestly the family that bought it
was like a couple with a little baby and
they needed to move and there was a
bunch of other details and stuff so i'm
happy i'm like totally like women
support other women yeah so i was happy
especially mary like i love mary yeah
are you guys the closest or is there
like someone that you're the closest
with on the show i mean i think i'm
close with everyone obviously i think
michelle and i have an extra little
special bond for whatever reason but i
think you know amanda and mary they've
known each other for 20 years right
everyone is a little bit closer right
somebody but we're all really close and
i have to say like it's not it's not
clicky and things like that which is
nice that is nice
this last season i felt like
i honestly i couldn't believe some of
the
behavior that came out of christine and
i was genuinely questioning i'm like is
someone capable of being this cold or is
it just sort of played up for the show
unfortunately it's you know it's really
like
might even be a little softened for the
show so yeah
see that's so fascinating to me because
i think a lot of people we also have a
lot of listeners that write in
what to do when there's someone in your
workplace that is making it a negative
environment for you how have you even
off camera been able to sort of navigate
that
i mean for me i think you kind of see on
the show too and you could kind of look
at it two ways so you know when there's
someone that comes in that is negative
you know what i mean i don't engage i'm
not gonna be fake and i'm not gonna give
my energy to anybody that you know
doesn't deserve it and
so you could look it in you could be
like oh wow she didn't she didn't say
anything but it's like i would rather be
true to who i am i'm a super genuine
person i don't want to be fake i'm not
gonna be like hi love how are you like i
know what's going on behind closed doors
i know that you're out to get me so like
i'm just gonna you know be professional
in a setting and
don't give my energy to that because
totally because it showed that um one of
your clients was offered five grand from
her and she's coming out and saying that
all of the story lines are fake
convenient timings convenient time now
so i feel like not everything because i
we've done things on camera and it's
really hard after a while to like be
fake on camera because almost like your
most self is on it because you're like
trying to stay on camera like at least
put yourself together but like
our emotions higher when these like
situations happen because there's a
camera in front yeah i mean well not
only that it's like first of all they're
catching moments on camera that like you
know you never know what you're walking
into yeah i didn't know she was gonna be
at the dog party you know what i mean
right producers keep things obviously
you know secret so that they have those
natural moments
so like you know
like
it's hard to say like okay convenient
timing to say fake storyline yeah right
exactly when you do something bad and
then now it's a fake storyline no
totally you know just to kind of like
clear your name and stuff like that i
just don't agree with that has this
experience made your life better or
worse since the show came out
i mean i definitely i jumped in and i'm
embracing it and it's a new experience
and it's a journey and there's ups and
downs but
overall you know i'm really glad that i
joined the show i'm really good right so
many people write me all the time that
you know i've inspired them to go out
and and start a business or i inspired
them
they were in a rut and they were you
know in their bed and kind of like going
through depression or whatever it was
and watching the show inspire them to go
out and you know do something so if it
just helps one person that's what i'm
saying
you know and i mean i have to say like
the majority of the response that i get
from people is
so much love you know i get so much well
it's hard to not like you
i think that the show portrayed you
really well because sometimes it could
go either way without editing and and
all of that tv magic but i think you
were probably the most likable character
yeah we're not just saying seriously
but going back to how it's affected your
life
you know
you got pretty cozy with the most
handsome
developer i've ever seen
i don't even know property developers
were built like that right exactly
amazing did your relationship ever
continue with him after filming so we i
was actually just listening we were
driving me and my cousin here right now
and i was listening to a voice message
from him so we're definitely still yes
wait you guys send voice voice notes
yeah the voice notes yeah okay we were
talking about this a few episodes ago
we're like is that a red flag or is that
a good thing do you like voice notes oh
i do yeah oh you like them i do but do
yours expire
oh i keep them all oh yeah see that's
the difference i keep them out in case i
want to replay especially he has a cute
little southern accent oh yeah
yeah oh that's sweet though so you guys
are still communicating we're still
communicating i mean we're not like
officially boyfriend girlfriend yet
but that's because too he
obviously is developing the property but
he also is based out of texas oh and
like i did the long distance thing with
my high school sweetheart so for me it
was he's actually moving here in the
next month so oh wow so maybe
[Applause]
that would be awesome
sunset productions like yeah no one
please anything that's amazing yeah so
and it's kind of fun because you have
this period right now to sort of really
get to know before you jump into
everything exactly
i mean i love that does like public
dating though and like we're not
publicate public eye dating kind of
scare you or are you okay with it
because you said you're a private person
well i don't have a choice no well no
you don't have a choice but how does it
i would not say that there's no
hesitation there it's definitely scary
to date because it's like you know the
media takes things twists things right
you know and also too you know they also
label if you end a relationship as oh it
was a failed relationship right well you
know even you know people make yeah it's
not necessarily a failure relationship
you learn you know like my high school
sweetheart i grew with him i you know
became a woman while dating him i don't
regret that that wasn't a failed
relationship that just got me to where i
am today you know what i mean right even
was my last relationship and i think
everyone needs to kind of think about
that too and realize just because you
don't end in a marriage it's not a
failed relationship i mean exactly it's
so different because if you were to put
a camera on everyone's life that isn't
on tv you could say
that couple failed and you failed at
that business venture yeah well i mean
it's so easy to do that but
i feel like
men must be intimidated by you yeah that
definitely happens a lot because i mean
not only stunning your own business
woman like you really don't need a man
at all oh i don't i'm like yeah even
everyone's like well why aren't you in a
relationship now it's like because
you're fine
i am the man like yeah exactly yeah but
so do have you ever experienced that
when you're going on a date with someone
and they're just like you're too much
woman for me like i want to be the man
and wear the pants and i know we wear
the pants yeah i know we always wear
pants i mean i definitely wear the pants
and also yeah
it's hard to knock them when you have
like a lot going for you and you're like
confident and you're like outspoken yeah
and i think people don't
i am where i am business-wise and
everything else because i have a
confidence about me it's not cocky by
any means it's just i know my worth i
know and i think in relationships i
think it gets tough too as as a man you
know what i mean when other people kind
of look like you know okay she's
obviously doing a lot yeah stuff like
that so that has been an issue in my
prior relationships for sure is there
something that you're like looking for
in a guy that
would make it like better like what
would he have to do to make you go okay
like he's different
i mean for me it's a family's super
important so i think you know just a guy
that just really invested in family and
like yeah it honestly doesn't really
matter if they're successful like how
successful right anything like that i
mean i am successful on my own so that's
not a huge thing for me yeah but if
they're not like i just need the
confidence to be there because i want
someone to support me and be happy for
me right whereas like i've been in you
know relationships where you know
sometimes my success would threaten them
and yeah that's what i mean
and finding a confident man honestly is
harder than you think today especially
if you're is this why this guy is
different is he confident he's
definitely confident okay you know and i
think that you know there's definitely
something to still be explored there to
see where it goes
is that because that was shown in 2019.
have you guys just been talking for like
no no no this was shot this was shot
this past year oh the only 2019 was that
once
i was like wait a minute i got my thing
so i'm like he has been talking for that
one no
nothing's developed
is talking stages like what am i doing
i'm really excited to see this play when
does the next season start for selling
sunset we don't exactly know when it
starts filming and it's not even like
i'm not telling you like this is no so i
think we're probably would start filming
junish but that's a total guess so oh my
god well is there something that
you would like to
showcase more on the season maybe your
empanada business or is there something
that you're like i actually just got
into costco so yes okay let's talk about
it let's talk about it so you have a
vegan frozen empanada business
and they're so cute by the way i've seen
them like have you tried them no wait i
have to pay i'm getting you that oh my
god
i'm going to show you a huge big cool
light
i love it i love an empanada how did you
fall into this so i grew up in the food
industry my grandfather started a
company
yankee trader seafood it was obviously
seafood based started it out of his
kitchen you know it was a really small
my mom and my uncle they took it over
and so i've been in the industry my
entire life and and i just knew after
coming out to los angeles i knew the
plant base was gonna be a big thing
right so i wanted to start my own
company and kind of do something that
was you know a mix between my family so
i'm still involved with you know because
it's so important to me and also
bringing something a little bit
different to the table and
you know first to market no one's really
taken over the vegan frozen
um and so i have empanadas i also have
the spring rolls coming out
so like i i'm a [ __ ] for a spring roll i
love that i'm excited and i i'll i'll
add them into the cooler stuff oh
perfect have you always been very
ambitious and driven always so what what
how did you know that you wanted to be
an entrepreneur i think from a really
young age you know i always loved
babysitting i love kids so like i loved
making money ice cream shop my parents
had to sign the little waiver to say
because i was under 16 or 18 whatever
that you had to do for like the working
thing
and i remember them signing it away so
that i could work i loved making money
saving money and i loved math i was
always like excelled in math um not me
you're the kid that every parent dreams
about like
my dad is saying that my dad used to
like he cut up my thongs oh my god oh no
no no yeah you wouldn't oh my oh yeah i
would go crazy oh my dad was oh i okay i
would actually get so sent home a few
times from school for my outfit so yeah
well
you were were you a little rebellious or
did you have really just strict parents
no my dad was strict and my mom is wild
so like you have the best school oh my
god my mom's like the mom from mean
girls so like i would get dressed up for
christmas time with like stockings up to
here the tiniest little skirt and my mom
would be taking pictures like yeah
yeah and my dad my dad would be like you
are not leaving the house like that is
so like my mom oh my god my mom yeah my
mom was like the mom that you know i got
i remember i got in trouble once
my dad took my cell phone away for a
month my mom went out the next day
bought me a new stuff on twitter tell
dad yeah yeah yeah
don't tell dad oh your mom is epic did
you learn from your site because you
have great style is that where you got
it from definitely not my mom oh yeah
my cousin's here like you know and so
you probably had the
the ability to like try everything
because of her you're like okay my mom
might kind of encourage me to wear
whatever i want oh yeah yeah she was
super supportive whatever i wanted to
wear yeah oh yeah yeah no like when i
say she's the mom from mean girls she's
the mumbai
that's like the opposite for us and my
dad was a firefighter so like he would
work every four nights and it was like a
sleepover like you know that's the phone
so oh yeah don't worry my mom was
letting my boyfriend sleep over at the
time my dad would be like horrified yeah
my dad was like leave the door open and
we're like oh geez maybe you should just
go home yeah
like this is way too scary i remember
last season on the show that you said
you started investing in the stock
market as a teenager yes how did you
even know
what to do because i was freaking
learning how to braid my hair but you're
investing in the stock market so i told
you like i loved baby city at a really
young age one of the families that i
babysat for the husband went to harvard
very very intelligent obviously very
successful and i remember putting the
twins down for a nap and instead of
watching tv i went and sat in the office
and then i looked down and i saw his
christmas bonus and there was a lot of
zeros yeah and i was like oh [ __ ] i need
this i know you looked at this thing
you're like there's a lot of zeros there
that's how you make money this is how
you make money you invest it and at the
time you know what i mean i had just
started you know i was doing the ice
cream store i was babysitting and i also
was like doing little modeling things
yeah so i saved every single penny and
then started putting it into so
the first time that i invested i was
looking at what he was investing in and
then i excited to read so like if you
once you start because then once you
start reading about you know which
stocks you're investing in then other
little stock things will come up right
health care business and stuff like that
that was like one of the first ones that
did really really well wow like what
would you say to people that are trying
to get into the stock market and they're
trying to learn how to invest like we're
gonna start i think that people think
that they have to have like fifty
thousand dollars to invest like you
could put a thousand dollars in you know
something yeah just start dip your toes
in the water right and then once you
start to see it you know go up and
double or triple or whatever it is
you're like oh wow then you become more
into it yeah then you start reading more
and i think you know people just need to
really go out there and just try it yeah
we were told when we started investing
to invest in stock for companies that
you like personally so it's like we're
on amazon every day so it's like we're
gonna invest in amazon exactly and think
about if you invested in amazon 10 years
ago five years ago not exactly only but
you're you're really smart because you
like to find uh even the companies
you're an angel investor before they
even start up so why did you ever want
to become an angel investor because
there's al it's risk in that there's a
lot of resistance
investors to people that don't know what
it is so basically you're investing more
so in a startup yeah the simple version
is you're investing in a startup and i
think that you know being part of a
company and watching it grow for me is
just something that you know you're
basically like creating yeah yeah you
know and even though you're just
investing in it you're watching it
become something so i remember investing
in wheels i'm sure you've seen the
wheels riding around yeah but i invested
in it before there was even a bike wow
so you know it's really you have to be
able to have like somewhat of a creative
mind and yeah like a visionary you know
exactly and i invested in it because a
lot of my friends were having accidents
on the lime scooters and the wheels were
they're a lot safer so like little
things like that you know what i mean
that's just one of like the many that
yeah what's your favorite that you've
invested in so far i did invest um in a
cbd company really early on and i did it
because i think if something can make a
difference in somebody's life and and my
friend at the time was working with them
and
so what happened was like
someone that he was taking care of he
was taking care of this child that he
was about like maybe eight or 12 or
something but he was having like
anywhere from like 20 to 60 seizures a
day and they i mean his parents were
super successful they couldn't get the
seizures to stop and the only thing i
mean they had him on like top medicine
the top medical people were examining
him right this cbd was the only thing
that could get them to stop and i was
like you know what if this can make a
difference in somebody's life and truly
make a difference it's a quality product
that's true that's why you know i like
to invest in things that make a
difference for people that's awesome i
mean i love that but i would be so
nervous to invest in a startup before
you even see a product because the
patience you have to have for that you
have to have a lot of i have no patience
yeah yeah so i actually recently well a
couple years ago invested in a company
nanotech which is um i went to ucla and
went to usc
oh yeah i don't know i just just for the
meeting
i'm like oh god it's going to be out
there i didn't go to
ucla no no just for the meetings
yes we have to do backtracks around here
but no i remember going into the meeting
and for that and it's it's this battery
thing that i do think is going to change
the market and
be a really big thing but i remember
walking into the meeting this is like
actually funny because nine times out of
ten i walk into a meeting and it's
all men and they're looking at me like
who is this girl and i've actually been
laughed out of meetings before i was
literally going to ask you look then
laughs out of me oh it's so not okay
because i was going to say you're so
beautiful and you're so well spoken
literally in person she's exactly the
same as she's tv
but it's it's hard when you're a female
boss because even with us in our podcast
no one sometimes takes this seriously
because you get completely stereotyped
for whatever hundred percent does that
happen to you often when you walk into a
room like more times than i can even
talk about been laughed out of meetings
ben you know everyone's one looking
around to see who if am i someone's
girlfriend am i someone's wife why is
she why is she the only girl in here and
it's like why should i and they expect
me to dress a different way because of
that it's like no i'm gonna wear what i
want and i'm gonna be who i am and i've
been told too you can't dress like that
you can't post in bikinis and be taken
serious in a business world well guess
what i am and i'm gonna continue to do
it was there a moment that really
affected you and it hurt your feelings
that someone like diminished what you've
done like your accomplishments have you
always been like i had like i don't care
no i mean there's been i mean plenty of
moments where people have literally
looked around and been like is she i've
she is she with you oh
no no i've been told i think you're in
the wrong place wow so i mean plenty of
moments that like oh okay but i mean i
just walk in it empowers me to walk in
right you know okay i'll wait for my
time to talk i'm not gonna talk over
everyone but when it's my time to talk
i'll show you oh yeah i mean right we we
have all been there and i have to say
proving people wrong is like the
sweetest it's kind of like it's the
sweetest revenge
how do you approach if you're gonna if
you know that you're about to approach a
room full of like a ton of men or
whatever that you know are gonna
underestimate you do you do something
before you're like i know that this is
gonna make me like have my head on
straight and
you know just anything that you do
before no but i think that when i walk
into a room now even more than ever is i
walk in with the utmost confidence and
shake their hands so stern i've actually
been told numerous times like from
people's hands that have shaped they've
gone to like friends that i've known
they're like
they still talk about how strong my hand
is our daughter
it is it's really important you know and
just to establish yourself
and i always am very respectful and
polite and i wait for my time to talk i
never jump in before right but then you
know i add a few extra little you know
points here and there and words that
they're like oh [ __ ] she knows that
does she know that you know i think that
when a woman because there is a
stereotype still unfortunately that
lives today that you have to be very
dainty and like delicate yeah but when a
woman comes in with a firm handshake
yeah that is better i'm telling you it's
something that likes the tone it does it
really does they're like i love it yeah
i mean i love it i think that is so
relatable to so many women listening
because i feel like you know sophie and
i
have a very well-known family and when
we walk into the room and we're trying
to
make ourselves known as an individual
so many times people don't take it
seriously i've walked in and they laugh
at me before they're taking me as a joke
just to see if i mess up and
it is something that like you know what
you're gonna laugh now but watch me do
better exactly it really does motivate
you to work work harder so out of
everything that you've accomplished in
your life so far what is something you
are the most proud of
you know obviously i have all these
businesses and i've done really well
with all that but at the end of the day
like for me family is everything yeah
and they'll continue to be everything
and my relationship with my family and
the fact that you know they'll always
come first to me i love you know i mean
that just shows you that you can have
pretty much everything or people can
look at you and say she has everything
like the businesses probably the guys
anything she wants to close but at the
end of the day it's your family and it's
so important to establish that 100
they're like my whole world and and i
can't wait to have a family myself do
you know how many kids you want oh my
god i want so many babies but no a
village uh i have a village names
i do i have a few picked out like i have
a little list in my phone boy girl
everyone has a little i don't i do i
need it oh my god i have like a list on
my phone of like the all the like i have
guy and then it's like all of the guy
traits that i want in my future i think
it's really great to manifest
do you manifest and do it i do like i
mean oh i love that not like officially
but
you know like i definitely believe that
i manifested my life to be honest with
you right you know i think what you put
out to the world you receive back and
and i do think if you're a good person
you know good things happen to you you
know i do things not because i want
people to notice you know i mean i'm the
type of person where like
you know i mean at the grocery store if
somebody if the credit card's not
working i'll step in i don't do it so
that i can tell people about it or
you know i don't do it even my dad like
my dad's always and i learned this from
him for sure he's always the one like
helping you know the elderly person
across the road right like
i mean like he's just so it's free yeah
you know being a kind person it's almost
harder to be mean to people the easiest
thing in the world to do is to be kind
and so many people forget that that's
you know the
recipes a happy birthday
happy world your family sounds awesome
yeah they're great they're wild and
great and i love them
you can relate you got a few nuts in
there but you know
that's what makes it exactly right
that makes it fun so we thought we'd
wrap up this episode with a quick
rapid-fire segment we're calling
advising from emma
ooh so we're gonna ask you a few
questions and you can just sort of like
shoot the answer off okay all right i'll
try and be quick best place in the u.s
to buy a home
i think either los angeles or miami
right now um
i love my favorite thing you're going to
make actually i'm going to add uh texas
to that as well texas a m i think it's a
great it is really fun a lot of our
friends like it how can you elevate an
outfit
ooh jewelry
jewelry and a nice pair of shoes in a
bag right yeah i know shoes really yeah
you could put the same outfit on and
then add different shoes like uh
yeah what is the first step into
starting your own business
i think starting your own business you
really have to know just put your whole
everything into it 100 into it and you
know start googling things that have to
do with whatever company you want to
start and if there's any competition
because you don't really want to start a
company but you know there was come
there's a company that i wanted to start
before and i googled it and it was out
there so you might have to pivot and
create something do your research do
your research for sure right right like
that how do you deal with toxic people
in your life
i don't engage
don't give toxic people your energy keep
your energy yeah exactly keep your
energy pure give it to good people yeah
it's better to keep your circles small
and good than large hundreds
best breakup tip for moving on
ooh live your best life stay busy go on
vacation
have some girl nights
that every you can tell like when i'm
like going through a breakup or like
ending your instagram she's out i am in
bikinis i am out i am oh my god that's
okay and i'm actually super sad this my
instagram is peeking
exactly
i would not die
and you have a good time
exactly would not know
exactly and then they're like a bikini
they're like why did she get hotter yeah
oh my god yeah
a little extra sexy
it's good to get broken up with like
every six months because then you just
get hotter every single day
it's like a little reboot you know every
time just get your body ready
yeah exactly
every six months
because you get a little like 0.5 water
yeah because you're a model tips to be
confident in front of a camera
oh i think this is actually a tricky one
because you know i remember growing up
in the modeling industry and i actually
hated it i hated
constantly being compared to other
people and i think you just have to know
that you are unique and even if you're
not picked for a casting or whatever it
may be you just weren't meant for that
and there yeah you know it's a different
path that you're supposed to go on and
things like that totally for sure also
you're
just so smart you can do so many things
like modeling can be one thing but like
you don't have to only have that you
know no exactly but one of my favorite
things is like business business yeah
you know that's sick so most important
qualities for you when you're finding a
man we know family oriented
family-oriented funny they have to make
money because i'm like funny and fun and
wild but like they have to be able like
you can't be right oh god you know what
i mean what are two like bad things
that you don't want in a guy
a cheater unfair someone that's not
loyal or bad at communicating because
i'm really good at communicating i've
been with a few bad communicators and
you know it's really difficult speaking
in morse code i'm like i
yeah what what is the conversation yeah
like let's communicate let's talk this
through oh my god i'll sit for hours in
bed like let's hash things out like i
want to figure out why you're behaving
this way you know like i need someone
that can communicate i can talk as well
intelligence i think communication and
intelligence goes hand in hand my mom
always taught us when we're looking for
someone to date make sure they're they
can teach you something exactly yes i
think learning in a relationship is so
important it's so important it is it
really is the last one is the worst
advice you received
that i can't do both that i can't post
in a bikini yeah that i can't be a
businesswoman because guess what i'm
doing it
drop the mic
this has been an incredible interview
with emma emma thank you so much for
coming oh my god thank you guys so much
for having me the most baller way to end
an episode
perfect it was sick so tell everyone
where they can find your social media
your empanadas everything okay well my
empanadas are now well they're online at
qvc and they're in costco go in the
northwest region they'll eventually be
in all the
they start with the northwest um but
online qvc online on my website my
instagram is emma hernan
oh perfect thank you guys so much for
having me i'm obsessed with you guys are
you kidding
i'm sweating i'm so excited okay thank
you guys so much for watching this
week's episode of the unwax podcast and
we'll see you next week bye
[Music]
you